bienvenidos al espacio de cultura de
france 24 esta semana aterrizamos kahn a
la cartelera de nosotros los mortales en
ocasiones el festival de la riviera
francesa tiene un universo tan propio
con una alfombra roja tan llena de
estrellas que se antoja inaccesible pero
uno tras su mística y una verdadera
devoción por el cine y dos no hay otro
evento que de gloria por igual al
consagrado y al principiante tal vez por
ello un trío de titanes con trasfondo
común se llevó la palma de oro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
lo que acaban de intuir es titán de la
parisina julio de cono no decimos ver
porque esta segunda obra de la autora
tiene múltiples capas y el consejo es
llegar puros a su visionado si bien su
base son nuestros cuerpos y aquellas
etiquetas de sexo raza clase que nos
imponen pero podemos borrar y rehacer
pese a los odios de ahí que sea una
cinta de amor sin género importa álex ya
que tras un accidente de niña vive con
titanio en su cuerpo de asesina en serie
es al huir de la policía que por
necesidad adopta la identidad de un
joven desaparecido a cuyo padre se
acerca
quiero a esta película porque al final
es alguien que está sola que no sabe
encontrar su lugar en el mundo y que
descubrirá su humanidad en contacto con
el personaje de van saun landon 10
sublime es como un titán que baja entre
los mortales y es muy muy bonito es
mitológico mi propósito es transmitir al
público que la cuestión de género no es
pertinente se trata de liberarse de
todas las ideas preconcebidas sobre lo
que debería ser un humano porque somos
tantos en este planeta cuyas opiniones
planet red en general los títulos
franceses o semi galos por sus actores
apuntan a sacudirnos benedetta también
es violencia y escatología pero con
erotismo y humor del neerlandés de
'instinto básico' o bajos instintos
volver joven vuelve a provocar con mojas
lesbianas del siglo 17 que asegura que
no es blasfemia sino un hecho real
y detrás hay una crítica a los dogmas de
la religión del cine del poder y ahí
entra el periodismo de fans de pain of
human que sólo por lea seguido de la
cinta en la vida de adele vale la pena
el mecanismo manipulador y llorica de la
televisión que es un retrato del frente
flash
si bien para periodismo en los que vivir
tipo the new yorker mejor wes anderson
diferentes patch prometía color simetría
y un elenco idealista en la francia del
siglo pasado pues según la crítica es
eso y además esos mil referencias
culturales una carta nostálgica al
oficio que nunca existió aunque eso no
importa
anderson nos guía hasta el amor en este
orden de amantes en un parís he
realizado por giacoia
de un drama de celos y masculinidad de
la húngara ildikó en jedi
y de los extraños' que inician un
romance en un compartimento de tren
recreado por el finlandés juho kuosmanen
como ven más que el palmarés queremos
bajar del cielo de khan las perlas de
esta edición que cuenta con un panteón
de cineastas el iraní asghar farhadi que
puede que recuerden por este filme está
entre ellos con la trama de un preso que
en una salida haya un bolso y lo
devuelve lejos de ser un héroe con una
sola cara se sumerge en la tensión y el
interés por la ambivalencia del
oscarizado farhadi sin parecerlo mucho
más cercanos el tailandés apichatpong
weerasethakul que junto a tilda swinton
crea el mayor homenaje a colombianos o
lo sensorial con una imaginación por lo
desconocido sino por la memoria de los
pueblos de la tierra y aquí de la sangre
derramada
hurtig
[Música]
hay un recuerdo colectivo que me
gustaría transmitir pero no para los
humanos solo sino desde las montañas las
plantas los insectos como dijo tilda
sobre las vibraciones creo que hay un
diálogo como si nos comunicáramos dentro
de una misma memoria somos una única
memoria
con ganas de que ningún nombre que vea
note en la japonesa drive my car de
ryosuke hamaguchi adaptada de un relato
de murakami en el que el arte es sanador
nuevo todos son conocidos también
libertad la única gran española con un
niño latino en la que clara brooker teje
con dos adolescentes del cruel
privilegio de clase
mi mamá trabaja para ustedes ya pero
debes comer a familia
qué descaro como que de las familias y
el inp el culo a su abuela y el resto no
lo hace desde que vas con ella y esta
pandilla de cuyos padres no cualquier
agua quizás suena cualquiera
abuela
cada vez que yo quiera
y es que amazon hará que desde agosto
solo nombremos al musical annette que
con leo caga a la batuta será un
espectáculo de cine desmedido sin miedo
al ridículo a la par que una dedicatoria
a la masculinidad tóxica desde dos
artistas como magia un cotilla y adam
driver como no caer en el encanto si los
sparks además ionizan y completan la
banda sonora con ellos nos despedimos no
sin antes avisarles que en este artículo
iremos actualizando fechas de estrenos
en españa y latinoamérica gracias y
hasta pronto cuídense
[Música]
es un egoísta